الخروج من سوق الحروب واسرائيل
ستدخل حربا مباشرة مع ايران.
تركيا التي ترشيحهما قبل قمة
الحلف المقبلة. العالم يريد
الروسي الاوكرانية. اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مساعدة عسكرية
سانا مارين ان طلبي العضوية لحلف
شمال الاطلسي الناتو الذين
قدمتهما فنلندا والسويد قد يجمدا
اذا لم يتم التوصل الى اتفاق مع
متهورا وغير حكيم لانها قد تتسبب
في تصعيد الوضع وزعزعة
درسا من الحرب في اوكرانيا?
العالم يتجه لازمة جديدة بسبب
بنسبة اربعين بالمئة. بينما خفضت
الشركة الروسية امداداتها الى
الاستقرار. اردوغان على السويد
وفنلندا اتخاذ خطوات واضحة
السلام ومعاقبة روسيا. جاز بروم
تخفض امدادات الغاز الى المانيا
الجمهوريين روسيا مسئولية التضخم
القياسي. تقرير استخباراتي غربي
الروسية عن المبعوث الروسي الى
السورية الكسندر لافرينتييف قوله
ان روسيا تعتبر عملية تركيا
العسكرية المحتملة في سوريا عملا
للاوكرانيين في مصنع ازوت. قال
الرئيس الاوكرانيسكي عن معركة
ايطاليا ايضا وبنسبة خمسة عشر
بالمائة. نقلت وكالة الاعلام
وحاسمة في مكافحة الارهاب. من
جانبها قالت رئيسة وزراء فنلندا
جديدة لاوكرانيا تشمل مدافع
وقذائف وصواريخ مضادة للسفن
دومباس هذه المعركة لها ثمن باهظ
للغاية بالنسبة لنا. انه امر
الهجوم الروسي يشكل خطرا على
اوروبا وليس على اوكرانيا وحدها.
نيويورك تايمز الموقف الغربي من
ازمة اوكرانيا بات منقسما بين
حيث افتتحت روسيا رسميا اول جسر
سريع يربطها بالصين عبر نهر
المدفعية الحديثة لاوكرانيا
سيضمن مصلحتنا وانهاء التعذيب
مخيف ونحن نلفت انتباه شركائنا
الى حقيقة ان عددا فقط من
الغربية. روسيا تهدم جسور
اوكرانيا وتبني جسورا مع الصين
الاستراتيجية صممت خلال الحرب
الباردة لاستهداف الاساطيل
الحرب على وشك الاندلاع فمن
يستطيع ايقافها. الم يأخذ العالم
الاوكرانيين صامدون ولا اعتقد ان
للروس القدرة على تحقيق تلك
واشنطن تتجه لحظر الاستثمارات في
الصين. الرئيس الامريكي يحمل
الشرقي لامريكا ضمن نطاقها وصنعت
روسيا ما يقارب خمسمائة طائرة من
ديمتري ميدفيديف متسائلا من قال
ان اوكرانيا ستبقى موجودة على
فلاديمير بوتين رغم الحرب في
واكد مواصلة الصين دعم امن
وسيادة روسيا مجازفا بتوتير
العلاقات بين بكين والدول
السيناريو الاقل احتمالا وهو
اكتفاء روسيا بما حققته واعلانها
لديها القدرة على حمل القنابل
النووية لالاف الكيلومترات حيث
الاهداف. لكن ما الذي يرمي
ميدفيديف الى قوله بتصريحه ذلك.
جين بينج التأكيد على قربه من
صديقه القديم الرئيس الروسي
بقيمة اجمالية تصل الى مليار
دولار. وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الحرب الروسية في اوكرانيا دخلت
مرحلة حرجة مع حصار الروس
تتمكن من القاء اربعة وعشرين طنا
من القنابل. هذه القاذفة
النصر. تهديد خطير وصادم. نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
منها مفترس السفن. الاحداث
والتطورات. جدد الرئيس الصيني شي
مفاجأة بوتين. مفاجأة جديدة قد
تغير قواعد الحرب باكملها. اثنان
وعشرون ثلاثة. طائرة روسية
بقدرات خارقة يحضرها بوتين للرد
يخطط للاستيلاء على جزء كبير من
الاراضي الاوكرانية ان لم يكن
البلد باكمله لكنني لا اعتقد ان
بامكانه تحقيق ذلك. لان
امون. مشروع قرار لتقييد
الاستثمارات الامريكية في الصين.
هذا الطراز شاركت في العديد من
الحروب واطلق عليها عدة القاب
اولا مواصلة روسيا تحقيق مكاسب
في شرق اوكرانيا. ثانيا وصول
خريطة العالم بعد عامين. من
جانبه قال مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي كولين ما زلت اعتقد ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
على السويد وفنلندا. وتوصف
بالقاذفة الجوية الاكثر فتكا
المعارك لطريق مسدود وتكبد
اقتصاد العالم خسائر ثالثا وهو
المعادية مداها نحو سبعة الاف
كيلومتر ما يجعل اوروبا والساحل
الرد غربيا هذه المرة ويتوقع
الغرب ثلاثة سيناريوهات للحرب.
التصريحات العدائية بينهما بعد
سلسلة من الهجمات والاغتيالات في
مستشار وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
نحن ممتنون للغرب ولكن نحتاج
تصريحات امريكا بين اليوم والامس
من جانبها اوكرانيا تستنجد
الداخل الايراني والذي اتهمت
ايران به اسرائيل بشكل مباشر. تل
يوجد مثل هذا الزر? ربما كان من
المفترض ان نوجد هنا وحدنا على
لاسلحة اسرع واقوى. فهل يعني ذلك
اقتراب الحرب من النهاية? ياتي
اسرائيل? وماذا لو تدخلت روسيا
في سد النهضة للرد على المصريين?
هذه الارض بشكل ما. اسمعتم ايها
فالحرب تغير وجهتها. من روسيا
ابيب تستعد لحروب مدمرة مع لبنان
وايران بعد تحالفات مع دول عربية
بالوقود جوا? يبدو انه لم يعد
هناك مجال للتوقف الحرب
واوروبا والغرب تأخذ الحرب
اتجاها اخر الشرق الاوسط على
الاسرائيلية الايرانية على
الابواب. اوكرانيا تستنجد. في
تصريحات خطيرة لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي قال لا يمكن تحمل خسارة
بالغرب لمدها بالاسلحة الثقيلة
لمقاومة الحرب الروسي حيث قال
والامارات. فهل هي الحرب اذا? هل
تتحول حرب الوكالة بين ايران
طائرات اف خمسة وثلاثين لضرب
ايران دون الحاجة للتزويد
صفيح ساخن بسبب التوتر بين
اسرائيل وايران مع احتدام
قامت بها اسرائيل ونشر منظومات
رادارات دفاعية في دول كالبحرين
الحرب التي تشنها موسكو على
اوكرانيا. واوضح مسؤولون ان
نهضة بينما تطور اسرائيل اسلحتها
لضرب ايران وفتيل الحرب يكاد
تلقائيا لمدة عامين. لماذا ايها
الفراعنة انسيتم ماذا فعلت بكم
يشحن شمالا الى السوق الاوروبية
بعقد يمتد الى ثلاث سنوات قابلة
صدمة غير متوقعة واجهتها روسيا
من ام مصر وقعت اسرائيل ومصر
اوكرانيا وسنزودها باسلحة بعيدة
المدى. ما هذا التناقض في
لهاتين الدولتين وروسيا تغلق
حنفية الغاز على المانيا
اسيا هذه المرة بعيدا عن
اوكرانيا؟ هل على العالم ان يدخل
وسط مساعي الاتحاد لتقليل
الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي في ظل
واسرائيل الى حرب مباشرة كما
توقع الامريكان? اسرائيل تطور
الغاز الطبيعي سينقل من اسرائيل
الى محطات اسالة في مصر. ومن ثم
والاتحاد الاوروبي مذكرة تفاهم
لتصدير الغاز الطبيعي الى اوروبا
وايطاليا فكيف ستكون ردة فعلهم؟
الفرعون المصري والدب الروسي في
في ازمة جديدة؟ بينما لم يخرج من
الازمة الاولى بعد؟ كييف تستنجد
الجرأة يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
ومصر توجه طعنة غير متوقعة
لروسيا بمساعدة اسرائيل والاتحاد
الاوروبي. فهل يردها بوتين بسد
امن روسيا من امننا. قالتها بكين
رغما عن الغرب. فما كل هذه
ايقاف انضمام السويد وفنلندا الى
الناتو وما الذي يجهزه بوتين
طريقة كانت وسط رصد لسيناريوهات
الحرب الروسية هل تستطيع تركيا
مسؤول اسرائيلي. لو كان لدي زر
لاخفاء العرب لضغطت عليه. لكن لا
بالاسلحة الثقيلة والغرب يواصل
دعمه السخي لكييف ولن يتقبل باي
يشتعل بين طهران وتل ابيب. فهل
تسحب هذه الحرب امطار العالم نحو
موسكو. فما الذي ينوي الروس فعله
يا ترى؟ والصين تعلنها للعالم
هذه الحرب التي قد تجوب الشرق
الاوسط باكمله.
اوكرانيا لن تكون موجودة على
الخارطة بعد عامين هكذا تقول